길 사한 꼬마 빌딩 스터디 드디어
30기를 모집을 합니다 저 꼬마빌딩
스터디는 2016년도에 시작해서 지금
8년 동안 스터디를 진행 중입니다
그래서이 스터디를 들으신 분이 약
1500분 정도 계시고 그중에
건물주가 되신 분이 한 150분 정도
건물 주분이 되셨습니다 그래서 제가
봤을 때는 1딩 투자할 때 반드시
들어야 되는 강의라고 저는 생각이
들고요 그리고 저희가 30기 동안
하면서 데이터가 좀 많 쌓였 아아
그래서 그 데이터를 통해서 정말 빌딩
투사할 때 도움이 될 만한 어 그런
내용들로 준비를 했으니까 어 여러분들
기대하셔도 좋을 것 같습니다 저는
강의를 1주차 5주차를 좀 맡았고요
1주차 때 지금 작년 투자사례 분석이
라는지 그리고 올해 빌딩 투자를
어떻게 해야 되는지지 좀 전반적인
상항에 대해서 제가 1주차 때 강의를
할 예정이고 그리고 2주차 때부터는
저희 그 2연 상무가 나와서 기본
개념 진짜 건폐율 용적률 아니면
수익률 계산하는 방법이라든지 이런 좀
좀 기본적인 내용을 가지고 2주차 때
강의를 할 예정입니다 그리고 2주차
때는 답사를 좀 준비를 했습니다
토요일 날 전에 모여서 강의 전에
이제 답사를 진행할 예정이고 답사는
2주차 때부터 5주차 때까지네 그리고
저희가 강남구의 지역을 좀 정해
놨거든요 그래서 담당 팀장 인솔하에
답사도 진행할 예정입니다 3주차 때는
저희 건축 강의를 할 진행할 예정이고
김준석 소장님 나와서 설계라든지 어
이런 강 할 예정이고 그리 만약에
시기가 좀 많다라고 하면 저희가
설계했던 건물을 직접 찾아가서 강의
시작 전에 직접 현장에서 설명드리는
그런 시간도 있을 수 있을 것
같습니다 그리고 저희 송영원 대표님
나와서 시공에 대해서 어 강의를 할
예정이고 그리고 4주차 때는 저
양재경 회계 사님이 어 오셔 가지고
빌딩 투자와 관련된 모든 세무 그니까
양재용 회계사님이 좀 다른 세무사님
회계사님이랑 좀 다른 점이 직접 빌딩
투자를 해 보셨거든요 투자자 관점에서
세모를 좀 풀어 주시 서입니다 그
마지막 5주차에는 성공 사례라 실패
사례를 좀 많이 말씀드릴 거예요 사실
유튜브에서 실패 사례를 말씀드리기가
좀 어렵습니다 그래서 실패 사례를 좀
중점적으로 말씀드릴 거고 제
개인적으로 생각하기에 되게 좋은 지역
좀 제가 명쾌하게 어 찍어 드릴
예정입니다 그리고 마지막으로 빌딩
관리에 대해서 좀 다룰 예정인데
전체적인 어 빌딩 투자에 있어서 좀
필요한 것들을 좀 다 준비를 했습니다
여러분들 좀 기대하셔도 좋을 것
같고요 그리고 저번 기수 저번 기수
수강생분의 저희가 좀 인터뷰를
준비했거든요 그래서 한번 좀 인터뷰를
한번 좀 보도록 하시죠 강의 내용은
어떠셨나요 어 제가 기대하고 생각하는
것보다 훨씬 더 실무적인 내용이
많아서 실질적으로 어 내가 계약을 할
때 조심해야 되는 부분이라든지 어떤
건물이 좋은 건물인지 원론적인
부분부터 실무적인 부분까지 실 실제로
사용할 수 있는 더 실용적인
강의였다고 생각합니다 인상 깊었던
부분은 무엇이 있을까요 어 매주 각
전문가분들이 나오셔서 자세하고
전문적인 이야기들을 해주셔 가지고
세무적인 부분이나 건축적인 부분은
일반인들이 평소에 적혀 되가 어려운
부분인데 그런 부분들을 정말 잘
채워주는 가능이 었다고 생각합니다
지인분께 추천할 의향이
있으신가요네 추천한 의사 있고요 제가
주말마다 이제 강의 나오고 인정가능
보고 친구 친구들이 되게 많이 구금해
해서 추천 많이 하고 있습니다
앞으로의 목표 한 가지 말씀해 주세요
어 제가 되게 작은 사무실을 운영하고
있는데 저희 사옥이 되 만한 그런
건물 하나 갖고 싶은게 꿈입니다 인상
깊었던 부분은 무엇이 있을까요 어
일단은 매주 각 조마다 팀장님께서
인장을 가는 부분이 굉장히
인상적이었는데 쉽지가 않은데 이렇게
일일이 실전에서 설명을 자세히 해
주시면서 같이 궁금한 점 이야기하면서
인장을 다녔던 부분이 굉장히 인상이
깊었습니다 지인분께 추천할 의향이
있으신가요 어네 건물주 사실 강의
듣기가 쉽지가 않은데 이렇게 정말
이쪽에 특화되어서 이렇게들을 수는
강의는 거의 없고 굉장히 알차고 좋은
강의라고 생각이 들어서 추천하고
싶습니다 앞으로의 목표 한 가지
말씀해 주세요 어네 저도 홍대에
건물을 가는게 꿈이라서 영 준비가
되면 영향이 되면 꼭 홍대의 공로를
가지고 싶습니다 강의 내용은
어떠셨나요 어 일단 강의 커리큘럼이
너무 좋았고요 그 전문가분들이 그냥
분야별로 잘 설명해 주셔서 너무
좋았습니다 지인분께 추천할 의향이
있으신가요 어네 뭐 건물 투자에
염두에 두고 있다면 당연히 체계적인
교육이나 공부가 필요하다고 생각하고
스 커리큘럼은 충분히들을 가치가
있다고 생각합니다 앞으로의 목표 한
가지 말씀해 주세요 정말 좋은 건물을
사서 좋은 수익
거드는게죠네 30기가 2월 24일
토요일 날 어 2시부터는 여러분들 좀
기대하셔도 좋을 거 같고 그때 반갑게
어 인사하도록 하겠습니다 여러분들
스터디에서 뵙겠습니다 감사합니다